i think your ability to create strong
complex women is quite remarkable
cersei lannister i love her she's the
first person i've
ever become attached to who's in an
incestuous
relationship with her brother and it's
an incestuous relationship that i root
for because i actually think that
they're a great couple the boy
won't talk and if he does i'll kill him
him let's start the king the whole
bloody lord of them until you
and i are the only people left in this
world
when you read a book or see a tv show if
if you got the hero
and you have the villain one is black
and one is white and everybody responds
to them the same way
we like to hero we hiss at the villain
then you're dealing with cardboard
if the characters are fully fleshed and
complicated
then people are going to react to them
differently just as if they were real
people
people watching the tv show are going to
tend to like cersei
more than people who are just reading
the books and that's due to the
brilliance of lena heady
and her wonderful performances cersei
she's giving her
a dimension of humanity and explaining
her
motivations and wonderfully nuanced
performance she loves her children
she does she loves the children that's
her redeeming feature that her
cheekbones
speaking of cersei uh we know that
tyrion is capable of being a very
you know a very good leader and jamie's
shown a lot more signs of it since its
journey with brienne
do you think that cersei could have had
that kind of leadership capability if
she wasn't
so paranoid in regards to protecting her
family and obsessed with
the uh the prophecy
that is completely clouding her judgment
and to a certain extent her sanity
well the prophecy is certainly one
factor her
own individual character i think is is
one factor in one sense and cersei is an
interesting
case uh and
it's as sort of a commentary on the
society that she lives in i
you know in one sense she's extremely
privileged she's the daughter of
one of the greatest houses in the realm
she's beautiful
she's she's rich she's uh entitled
um she is shown deference by
most people that she meets so you have a
situation of extreme
privilege that produces i think a
certain
attitude in people on the other side
though
she's also a woman in an extremely
patriarchal society where
you know on one hand she's being told
that she's better than everybody and she
has all these things and the other be
told no you can't do that
no that's not for you no your brother
gets that you don't get that
so you know that the conflict that that
creates in people i think is
something that's fun to explore and i've
certainly tried to explore it with
cersei
but they you know the other thing to
keep in mind though is certainly it's
not journey it's not over yet so
i'm only five books into it and there's
two more books to write
so uh keep keep reading all right do you
think her relationship with tyrion would
be
better um if her mother if their mother
had
survived or do you think there's just
sort of too many elements of personality
clash there
for that to have made as much of a
difference as she credits it with
i don't know i'm writing a story as it
happened what if stories i'll leave to
the readers to figure out
all right